recup wings are never any fun and like I
was just freaking thoroughness so were
we Wednesday's love island kicked off
with the most dramatic recup lling we've
seen yet things started off cool karo
chose ray elizabeth chose zach i sada
chose yemen and Alexandra chose Dylan
but when it came time for Emily to
choose she selected a guy that was
already coupled up with someone else
busting this left Weston's former
partner Kelsey feeling some type of way
and what happened next
we never saw coming right now I think I
need to do what's best for me
so right now I choose to remove myself
from Villa and I hope you guys
understand the waterworks were free
flowing as Kelsey said her goodbyes I
never wanted to be that girl game of the
day so with Kelsey removing herself from
the island Kira had her pick of the
three guys left
Jared Erik and Anton so the boy that I
want a couple up with is Jared I really
gave my all tried to find that you know
the best possible connection I could I
stayed true to myself and I wouldn't
have changed a thing about the moves
that I made or the connections that I
built six couples remain in the villa
but none of them can get too comfortable
as viewers were asked to vote for their
favorite duo and the bottom two risk
elimination on Thursday your votes
change No